are you distracted right now by music in
your head Charlie do you hear something
right now how how how can you how did
you know that can see me I can see you
and I see there I think there's a song
in you right now what is in your head
right now I'm replaying my performance I
just did of close to you and and I love
[Music]
the and I'm like now I'm thinking if I
can make
him like or
maybe
like the new
song it's great music is recycled and uh
so in other words you're talking to me
but you're distracted right now because
you're thinking of close to you and now
you're and now no I love this believe me
I'm not all that interesting and now
you're re you're rewiring the song close
to you and then you just wrote a song I
see that that could be a good song you
just were belting out there maybe and um
and and if it's not I mean when I when I
wrote attention it used to sound like
this it used to sound like a classical
[Music]
song and then I kind of sat on it for
like almost a year and then one day just
woke up and heard the bass
like
[Music]
so you never know um when an opportunity
could come along to use something like
that I wonder if it's going to be hard
for you to be married because if I'm a
woman I'm thinking is he listening to me
right now or is he just is he writing a
song in his head I mean you you are
consumed with music I definitely am I I
did gaze over at Brooke one night and
while we were watching Sex in the City
and and she she did look over
and say that like I I I've just she's
like are you okay you've been staring at
the ceiling for two and a half hours
just not not even looking at your phone
just just just thinking she can read my
mind officially now so she knows when
I'm and apparently you can
too